[Musik]
meinen heutigen gast brauche ich nicht
vorzustellen professor karl lauterbach
ist das gesicht der korona pandemie der
mahner die kassandra deren botschaft
keiner hören redl herzlich willkommen
bei phoenix hallo vielen dank ja
wolfgang kubicki hat ihnen eine rolle
angeboten im film apocalypse now stört
sie dieses image als katastrophen profit
nein ist also ist auch nicht zutreffend
aber damit muss ich leben in dem sinne
und also ich hab halt manchmal auf dinge
hinweisen müssen
die zu dem zeitpunkt keiner gerne gehört
hat das ist aber auch meine rolle wenn
ich ehrlich aufklären wie komme ich da
nicht drumherum
damit muss ich klarkommen dass ich
ausgerechnet also herr kubicki da
einreiht und also das ist ja eine
polemische also sagen wir festlegen und
das ist ein bisschen enttäuschend aber
ganz grundsätzlich muss ich damit
rechnen natürlich das hat sowas von
luther hier stehe ich ich kann nicht
anders
auch das gilt ja für viele
wissenschaftler ich bin ja damit nicht
allein also wenn sie meinetwegen melanie
brinkmann also anschauen oder christian
drosten oder michael meyer hermann also
viele der wissenschaftler die quasi sich
also ziemlich eingearbeitet haben und
auch international recht gut vernetzen
denn bleibt einfach nichts anderes übrig
als auf die eine oder andere gefahr
hinzuweisen
aber ich habe für mich selbst also immer
zum motto gemacht also ich bringe kein
problem
ohne einen lösungsvorschlag gleich
mitzuliefern weil also einfach nur das
problem zu benennen
das also zermürbt und das ist
demotivierend das möchte ich nicht daher
versuche ich auch immer eine lösung
anzubieten
ich vermute mal ist nicht besonders
angenehm wenn sogar der trainer des fc
bayern münchen eine anti lauterbach
wutrede loslässt ich bin nie ein fan von
bayern münchen gewesen dass es kein
geheimnis aber mich haben ja auch andere
kritisiert zum beispiel entwickeln wenn
ich richtig ja und rudi völler den also
aus leverkusen also den
wie man sehr geschätzt habe früher und
als auch herr watzke dortmund einfahren
den ich auch sehr schätze also hat sich
auch damit dass die fußballer
ausgerechnet also mich kritisiert haben
dass mir schon ein bisschen näher
gegangen
ich bin fußballbegeistert ich schaue die
sportschau jeden samstag also ich
genieße tatsächlich das fußballspiel und
hatte mich auch bei den geist aus
spiegeln getäuscht muss ich sagen das
habe ich ja ganz falsch eingeschätzt
habe habe ich auch ganz offen also
eingeräumt von daher damit muss ich
leben und mit herrn flick ist jetzt ein
gespräch geplant ich glaube da versöhnen
wir uns mit herrn watzke habe ich schon
gesprochen ist am sonntag das war ein
sehr gutes gespräch hat sogar spaß
gemacht wir wollen gleich nachher noch
ein bisschen mehr darüber reden wie es
ihnen persönlich so in dieser pandemie
geht aber zunächst mal zu den fakten
dieser pandemie monate lang hieß es wir
können nicht lockern
bevor die inzidenz von 50 erreicht ist
jetzt heißt es plötzlich 35 das hat
viele irritiert ja das ist auch schlecht
erklärt worden aber der hintergrund ist
eigentlich ganz einfach wir haben neue
mutationen bei 117 aus england dann b15
aus südafrika und sogar eine kombination
von baden die jetzt in südengland sich
verbreitet b 15 25 also das sind
mutationen die sind einfach ansteckender
und auch wahrscheinlich tödlicher und
wenn ich da die gleiche sicherheit haben
werde ich bei der alten variante der
sogenannten wildtyp variante bei 50
hatte muss ich die neue infektionszahlen
runter senken sonst kriege ich das nicht
in den griff und somit habe ich immer
sie gesagt also 35 ist das neue 50 war
das virus ist gefährlicher geworden
das kann man relativ gut sogar
berechnend wieso die 35 jetzt ungefähr
die sicherheit bringen die vorher mit
der 50 jahre alt war
aber es kam hatte unterstellte dass die
britische
mutationen ungefähr 30% ansteckender ist
oder warum jetzt von 15 35 eine
unterstellung also wir wissen
mittlerweile dass die britische nation
etwa 35% ansteckender ist das ist
mittlerweile epidemiologisch noch
biologisch nicht steht das nicht mehr
strittig
und dann muss ich einfach davon ausgehen
also wie schnell kann ich dann noch
reagieren wenn ich ausbrüche habe weil
die entwickeln sich dann ja sehr
fürchten oder sogar den ganzen monat
betrachter 35 prozent das klingt
zunächst nicht nach viel aber es ist bei
einem exponentiellen wachstum von
absolvieren ist das natürlich bedeutsam
das würde bedeuten über einen ganzen
monat hinweg also ist das etwa vier bis
achtmal so viel und wo ich dann am ende
des monats vier bis achtmal so viele
fälle hätte das ist wie eine neue
pandemie so muss man sich das vorstellen
jetzt schauen wir uns mal die zahl in
großbritannien und irland genauer an da
sind ja diese varianten sehr weit
verbreitet trotzdem ist es mit relativ
ich sage meinen anführungszeichen
normalen pandemie bedingungen gelungen
die ansteckungsraten in großbritannien
und irland auf ein europäisches
durchschnittsniveau zu senken
spricht das nicht gegen diese ich sag's
meine anführungszeichen alarmstimmung
die da gemacht wird rund um die marke
mutation dann also wir wissen dass der
lock down in irland und auch in england
also schärfer war als das was wir
derzeit praktizieren und somit würde man
vermuten dass wir in der lage sind die
alte welt trieb variante zu senken
aber die britische mutation würde sich
ausbreiten das würde man vermuten und
genau das zeigen die daten also
beispielsweise in baden württemberg da
wird ja mittlerweile fast eine voll
sequenzierung nach mutationen erhoben
und da sehen wir wieder anteil der also
mutation stetig steigt und wir sehen das
gleiche in berlin aber auch in köln aber
auch im großraum münchen und wir werden
das in der nächsten woche auch in den
bundeseinheitlichen zahlen sehen somit
also wir sind in einer situation unser
lockdown
um die welt trieb variante
zurückzubringen
aber ganz langsam krabbelt quasi die
mutations variante hoch und die wird
irgendwann mitte märz wird die so stark
verbreitet sein dass dann wahrscheinlich
mitte märz ändern mehr als auch wieder
die gesamtzahlen steigen werden der
britische lockt dann ist einfach große
das heißt das was wir im moment erleben
dass durch die lok down maßnahmen die
jede woche ich sag mal immer so um die
20 prozent weniger infektionen haben da
prognostizieren sieht das wird sehr
schnell sein ende finden wir kommen
nicht weiter und nicht sehr schnell
sondern es wird noch eine ganze zeit
dauern und dann wird auch die 35 wir uns
wahrscheinlich erreicht werden also die
35 haben wir viele kritiker haben
sozusagen abwegig dass es im winter nie
erreicht bei uns erwartungsvoll aber
tatsächlich die gute nachricht ist wir
werden die 35 erreichen das war jetzt
kein illusorisch es ziel also diejenigen
die da beratend unterwegs gewesen sind
war den letzten also entscheidung
die haben tatsächlich argumentiert die
35 das werden wir schaffen das klingt ja
im sommer unmöglich wir waren ja damals
irgendwo bei 150 bis 170 und so die 35
werden erreicht werden dass die gute
nachricht die schlechte nachricht ist
danach starkes wieder an
sie haben jetzt ja erklärt dass es eine
evidenz gibt dass die britische mutation
ansteckender ist gibt es denn auch der
evidenz dafür dass diese variante
gefährlicher ist auch für kinder und
jugendliche sie ist zunächst sah man
auch tödlicher und führt zu
hospitalisierungen bei erwachsenen das
wissen wir es wissen wir ehrlich gesagt
jetzt seit ein paar tagen war da gab es
eine vorläufige untersuchung
und dann gab es eine sehr detaillierte
untersuchung in england die also beraten
der einrichtung die das dort matthias
northug und durfte hat gestern noch mal
eine neue analyse gezeigt die lässt
eigentlich keine zweifel
das ist ungefähr 40 bis 50 prozent
tödlicher diese variante b 17 ob kinder
überproportional betroffen sind ja oder
nein das ist nach wie vor nicht klar
ich hätte gern eine antwort auf die
vorwürfe die aus der ecke der kommen die
sagen diese lockdown maßnahmen sind
übertrieben die sagen diese corona
mutationen werden benutzt um der
bevölkerung angst zu machen um sie
villiger gefühliger für corona maßnahmen
zu machen
ja so sein sagt planken sind die daten
zeigen etwas anderes also entweder
vertraulich der wissenschaft oder ich
vertraue der wissenschaft nicht und zum
beispiel die gestern publizierte
auswertung also der führenden
epidemiologen und virologen aus england
wo man die meiste erfahrung mit b17 der
staat die zeigt ganz klar es ist
ansteckender und es ist tödlicher somit
ist dass die wissenschaftliche evidenz
das gleiche sagen auch
spitzenwissenschaftler von der
harvard-universität von der yale
university aus damit beschäftigen sich
weltweit die klügsten epidemiologen und
auch theologen und da ist einfach die
frage vertraue ich der wissenschaft oder
vertauschte nicht wenn ich dann sage da
hat die regierung irgendetwas vor mit
uns und so dann ist das nichts anderes
als dass ich sage ich vertraue der
wissenschaft nicht dann bin ich aber
auch vor sie denn nur nach sondern
richten
befürchten sie persönlich denn dass wir
immer neue mutationen dieses virus
erleben werden und am ende werden auch
die impfstoffe nicht mehr wirken
das befürchte ich ehrlich gesagt nicht
in dieser hinsicht bin ich optimist also
es gibt andere die das befürchten ich
bin also eher optimistisch es gibt auch
wissenschaftler die glauben so wird es
kommen ich glaube das aber nicht ich
glaube dass also die gefährlichste zeit
für neue mutationen die ist die wir
jetzt haben wo sozusagen die fallzahlen
noch sehr hoch sind gleichzeitig aber
auch die zahl derer die bereits einmal
erkrankt waren oder die geimpft sind
schon zunimmt und in dieser kombination
ich habe schon viele geimpfte oder
bereits erkrankte und ich habe noch
viele fallzahlen das ist was man also in
der epidemiologie also die kritische
phase nicht und zwar deshalb war das
virus dann sowohl noch viele anstecken
kann also kann sich schnell ausbreiten
es kommt aber auch schon auf massive
widerstände die widerstände durch die
vorerkrankungen oder die also
vorerkrankung mit dem virus und die
impfungen und diese kombination das ist
wenn man so will
der soft spot für neue mutationen daher
sind wir jetzt in der gefährlichsten
phase für neue varianten später wenn
nicht mehr genug fälle da sind und die
impfungen wir wirken nimmt aus meiner
sicht das risiko für wirklich sehr
gefährliche varianten wieder ab jetzt
sagen sie wir sind gerade in dieser
gefährlichsten phase
diese phase jetzt in diesen tagen werden
in den meisten bundesländern die schulen
wieder geöffnet teilweise vorsichtig im
wechsel unterricht und zunächst mal die
grundschuld aber es wird geöffnet ist
das richtig ist dass verfrüht ist das
gefährlich es kommt darauf an wie man es
macht also wenn wir jetzt die
grundschulen öffnen würden es geht ja
erst mal nur haben die grundschulen und
würden das ohne besondere
vorsichtsmaßnahmen nach wir werden
überlegen wir machen das also dass wir
mal deswegen halbvolle oder auch etwas
mehr als halb volle klassen zu lassen
und wir lüften dann gebe es bei den
kindern eine massive welle
das ist ganz sicher aber dafür ist es
einfach zu anstecken und wir haben also
bei den kindern also die in ländern
gelebt haben wo man so vorgegangen ist
haben wir sehr sehr hohe
ansteckungszahlen bei kindern gesehen
also mit 117 insbesondere somit wird man
jetzt öffnen man versucht es also wir
öffnen
wir lüften und ansonsten gelten die
üblichen hygieneregeln dann gevelsberg
grundschulkindern gebe es eine ganz
massive welle
wenn man es aber jetzt vorbereitet und
würde wechsel unterricht kombinieren mit
einer antiken testung der kinder
da würde es schon reichen wenn die
schulklassen einmal pro woche konsequent
getestet werden dann würde man die
ausbrüche um 75 prozent senken somit die
frage ist nicht ob sondern wie man ist
da würd ich gern ein haken in österreich
werden jetzt die schulen oder sind die
schule jetzt geöffnet worden und man
testet jeden
schüler jede schülerin zweimal die woche
warum bitte macht man das in deutschland
das werden wir jetzt tun also das ja der
vorschlag den ich gerade noch gemacht
habe und weshalb wir die tests nicht
etwas früher zugelassen haben und
weshalb es dort widerstände gibt das
wäre ja jetzt eine art regierungskritik
die stattfinden müsste daran beteilige
ich mich definitiv nicht aber ich
verstehe das so das hätte man ein paar
wochen schneller haben können in
österreich gibt es das schon
naja mag so sein aber wie gesagt dass es
nicht also ich gucke einfach nach vorne
und schlage vor dass wir es jetzt machen
das haben wir ja sehr intensiv über die
schulen gesprochen
es wird immer heftiger eine generelle
öffnung strategie gefordert also
entweder ein genaues datum oder
wenigstens eine genaue incidence zahl ab
wann dürfen sportclubs dürfen
gaststätten wieder aufmachen ab wann
darf man zum beispiel an ostern in den
urlaub fahren ist es nicht notwendig den
leuten so eine perspektive zu vermitteln
dass den ich von der stange gehen
das ist genauso unsinnig wie wenn ich
jetzt sage ich lege fest an dem und dem
tag wird der patient entlassen kann
wieder in einer occident vielleicht sein
ab der inzidenz haben gleich dazu aber
also so der arzt sagt also ich entlasse
sie in einer woche egal wie gut es ihnen
dann geht oder ob sie dann fieber haben
oder ob die wunde noch auf ist oder also
ob wir vielleicht das so noch mal
operieren muss in einer woche also
kommen sie wieder nach hause
das kann ich einfach nicht machen bringe
ein simples beispiel die inzidenz wenn
ich jetzt mache ich mache das an der
inzidenz wer ist ja incidents womit
hätten wir jetzt beispielsweise eine
deutlich tödliche variante b 11 7 ist ja
tödlicher die kombination die jetzt
droht b1 25 das ist also eine variante
die möglicherweise ansteckender und
tödlicher ist da ist die gleiche instanz
eine viel schlechtere nachricht als wenn
ich also die gleiche instanz habe mit
einer variante die nicht so nicht so
tödlich
oder stellt sich vor ich habe jetzt also
eine variante die mehr jüngere befällt
und mehr kinder befällt ich muss doch
auf all diese dinge reagieren können
somit ist der wunsch nach simplen regeln
verständlich aber der ist nicht wirklich
gut zu bedienen
kritiker werfen denjenigen die so
argumentieren wie sie die sagen wir
können den lockt dann noch nicht beenden
werfen sie vor sie würden die
kollateralschäden zu wenig
berücksichtigen also das was an anderen
krankheiten nicht behandelt werden kann
die psychischen die wirtschaftlichen die
sozialen folgen was entgegnen sie denen
also ich lese zum beispiel und habe ich
nicht alleine ich ärgere mich über diese
kritik oft oder ich lese die studienlage
und auch die berichte die es gibt zu
diesem kollateralschäden natürlich
genauso präzise wie die studien zum
eigentlichen virus und zur epidemiologie
das also alten das virus geschehen ist
das tun übrigens auch am 3 ich bringe
mal ein beispiel also christian drosten
der macht sich jeden tag gedanken
darüber was also hier mit kindern
passiert was in der gesellschaft
passiert und die idee dass ich meine
trägen die virologen die droste nur mit
der oberfläche des virus beschäftigen
oder mir ging es nur um die fallzahlen
und so weiter und so fort
das ist abhängig natürlich sehen wir
dass andere auch aber man muss die
schäden also im auge behalten um die es
hier auf beiden seiten geht ich bringe
mal ein beispiel
es wird auch darüber gesprochen also
jetzt kommen viele depressionen
also für diejenigen die alleine sind das
stimmt aber wie viele menschen werden
depressionen bekommen weil sie zb longo
lied wir wissen dass solon profit sehr
häufig dazu führt dass menschen
depressiv werden weiß er und so dass sie
brain vorläufig sie können sich nicht
mehr richtig konzentrieren viele sind
nicht mehr arbeitsfähig
sie kommen nicht mehr richtig in den
beruf hinein viele man noch plötzlich
die frage kann ich weiter meine existenz
erhalten bin ich wieder sah man
irgendwann wieder voll funktionsfähig
wir haben jetzt noch mit leute aus der
ersten welle die sind nicht mehr richtig
in der lage die arbeit zu machen die sie
vorher machen konnte programmierer
beispielsweise die nicht mehr den
code richtig zusammen bekommen so das
sind ja auch alles fälle so wird das
muss alles betrachtet werden und wenn
wir das also betrachten muss es ausbaden
sagen sagen aber es darf nicht einseitig
gesagt werden auf der einen seite sind
die depressionen die psychischen schäden
und auf der anderen seite sind nur die
toten sondern auf der anderen seite das
sind neben den toten spitze des
eisberges nochmal das ist noch mal ein
riesiger eisberg von leuten die ganz
erhebliche konsequenzen haben
einschließlich der familienmitglieder
die darunter leiden also wenn jemand
erkrankt oder vielleicht verstirbt ein
interview dass sie der welt gegeben hat
haben im dezember das hat irritationen
ausgelöst weil sie nämlich zukünftigen
klimapolitik und klimakrise gesagt haben
zur bewältigung des klimawandels seien
maßnahmen nötig so und dann jetzt
wörtlich die iren die analog zu den
einschränkungen der persönlichen
freiheit in der pandemie bekämpfung sein
wie haben sie das denn gemeint also ich
kann ja jetzt beispielsweise weniger
reisen
weil also die reise begrenzungen
notwendig sind damit wir nicht das virus
von einer region wo hohe prävalenz ist
in einer anderen region übertrage ich
muss auf viele dinge verzichten
die ich gerne machen würde weil es
schädlich wäre für die öffentliche
gesundheit somit schenke ich meine
freiheiten ein stück weit ein um die
pandemie zu bekämpfen
wenn ich jetzt die also klimakrise nach
vorne denke da gibt es zwei
möglichkeiten dass du sie im jahr eine
möglichkeit ist das so zu sehen
wir können alles machen was wir wollen
das wird demnächst alles was wir wollen
wird möglich sein durch eine technologie
die also dass klimaneutralen art ich
sage mal grüne ökonomie also die
magischerweise jede freiheit zulässt
ich kann so viel reisen die ich will so
viel konsumieren wie ich will
die technik macht es möglich das ist
alles dann klimaneutral
ich halte das einfach als
naturwissenschaftler für unmöglich oder
sehr unwahrscheinlich dass das gelingt
das ist augenwischerei ich glaube dass
wir bestimmte beschränkungen akzeptieren
müssen wollen wir den klimawandel
beherrschen dazu wird zum beispiel
gehören dass wir nicht also so viel
reisen wie jeder reißen könnte
dazu wird also gehört dass wir den einen
oder anderen konsum auch freiwillig ein
schenkeln diese einschränkungen der
freiheit sind freiwillig einschränkung
der freiheit und nicht unbedingt an
schenkungen der freiheit die jetzt quasi
per gesetz kommen das können auch
einschränkungen der freiheit sein die
indirekt kommen indem zb die preise für
bestimmte dinge die klimaschädlich sind
höher werden und somit ist also aus
meiner sicht schon eine analogie zu
sehen zwischen der bewältigung einer
solchen pandemie und das klima waren das
ist die einschränkungen jetzt in der
pandemie die sind ja nicht freiwillig
also ich kann ja im moment ich darf ja
im moment nicht nach mallorca fliegen
insofern wenn sie diese analogie zieht
ja keine freiwilligen einschränkungen
die analogie gilt für einige
freiwilliger einschränkungen sehr wohl
es ist einiges ist verboten aber anderes
da appellieren jedoch nur wir
appellieren doch jetzt an sie dass sie
so wenig sagen wie möglich auch dort wo
es erlaubt ist zum beispiel
geschäftsreisen sind hier erlaubt
trotzdem appellieren wir daran dass so
wenig übrig oder meinetwegen home office
wir appellieren an die betriebe so viel
home office wie möglich zu machen damit
man sich nicht ansteckt in betrieb das
ist ja nicht verboten war in den betrieb
zu kommen
und also ich die analogie betrifft hier
den freiwilligentag ich würde übrigens
auch noch nicht was für ausgeschlossen
hatten dass wir in der klimakrise in
eine situation kommen wo wir das ein
oder andere tatsächlich sogar verbieten
müssen aber aber das ist doch genau das
was manche kritiker jetzt befürchten
dass die einschränkungen die in der
karoo corona pandemie benützt werden als
blaupause für so was ich sage es ihnen
anfangs zeigen wie eine klima diktatur
ja aber das sind noch
verschwörungstheorien
wieso sie haben doch gerade erzählt daß
die carola maßnahmen vorbild sein soll
müssen für die noch viel größere
klimakatastrophe vom vorbild habe ich
nicht gesprochen sondern ich habe immer
gesagt dass einschränkungen der
persönlichen freiheit dass ich bestimmte
dinge macht bestimmte dinge die jetzt
beispielsweise andere gefährden und auch
mich gefährden in der pandemie
ich denke ich derzeit allen freiwillig
weil ich einfach teil der lösung nicht
teil des problems sein will und genau so
wird es auch bei der klimakrise sein da
werde ich bestimmte dinge freiwillig
nicht machen weil ehrlich gesagt möchte
ich auch bei der bewältigung der
klimakrise der nächsten generationen zu
liebe nicht teil des problems sondern
teil der lösung sein
und da ist die analogie aber jetzt zu
sagen also dass wir also dass ich nur
auf den verbots stahlkuppel
das ist doch eine verschwörungstheorie
als erster eine blaupause wir geben aber
der punkt war doch der wir hätten ohne
eine technische lösung hätten wir also
in europa die krone krise nicht in den
griff bekommen und werden uns die
impfungen nicht gelungen hätten wir es
nicht geschafft
wir lösen das zum schluss technik und
eine solche simple technische lösung wir
haben irgendwie wird's bei der
bewältigung der klimakrise nicht geben
das ist meine befürchtung
ich habe ja gesagt wir wollen uns auch
noch darüber unterhalten wie es ihnen
persönlich geht in diesem klima pandemie
blicken wir noch mal anderthalb jahre
zurück da haben sie kandidiert für den
parteivorsitz in der spd sind am ende
auf dem vierten platz gelandet viele
haben gesagt na ja mit der karriere von
karl lauterbach geht es vielleicht zu
ende jetzt in dieser corona pandemie
sind sie plötzlich wieder ganz vorne in
der ersten reihe der politik war es
einfach eine gelegenheit die mussten sie
ergreifen
also ich habe zunächst auch mal als ich
angefangen habe mich mit dem thema
auseinanderzusetzen habe ich nur daran
gedacht also was bedeutet das für mich
jetzt karriere technik also ich bin
sowieso nie jemand gewesen also der also
zum beispiel auch meine kandidatur für
den parteivorsitz der spd war ja eine
hochrisiko kandidatur und zwar deshalb
mit nina scheer damals also versucht
habe die spd sehr viel stärker neu
auszurichten in richtung einer partei
die also pionierarbeit leistet beim
schutz gegen den klimawandel
es war wenn man so will eine
neuausrichtung der partei die ich
versucht habe und das war ein großes
risiko dass man da nicht also unbedingt
gewinnen muss das war klar
aber ich bin einfach von dem klimawandel
so sagen wir mal angefasst von dem was
da kommt dass ich das auf meine pflicht
gesehen habe
und so ist es auch hier mit also
bedrohungen durch soko fit gewesen als
ich begriffen habe damals war ich gerade
in boston und anhaben school of public
health wo ich gute freunde habe die
spezialisten für virus epidemiologie
sind verboten wir klar das wird also
sehr riskant sein dass wir dann das war
die ganze welt betreffen und verändern
es war mir sehr klar geworden
außerdem gespräch mit mit diesen leuten
also mitte februar ende februar dass ich
gedacht habe okay ich würde einfach
einen beitrag zur lösung dieses problems
leisten weil da habe ich eine gute
ausbildung ich bin epidemiologe und bin
aber auch politiker und damit habe ich
mich einfach an die arbeit gemacht aber
ich habe nur daran gedacht was bedeutet
das jetzt für mich karriere technik das
ist das hat das hat mich nicht also das
war damals definiere die das war für
mich keine überlegung ich würde trotzdem
interessieren wenn sie sich da so rein
stürzen in die arbeit ich weiß ja sehr
arbeiten tag und macht an dem problem
sie haben hunderte von interviews an
anfragen keine politiker war so häufig
in talkshows wie sie schreiben hunderte
von tweets überlegen sie dann gar nicht
was das für sie persönlich bedeutet
nicht nur für die karriere sondern auch
für ihre gesundheit und all die
anfeindungen denen sie da ausgesetzt
sind die schnelle und ehrliche antwort
ist nein das ist eindrucksvoll
weil es hat ja nun wirklich negative
konsequenzen für sie ich würde gern noch
mal einen twitter zeigen den sie vor
wenigen tagen abgesetzt haben ich darf
mal vorlesen erneut rollt eine hass
welle über mich im internet mit mord
drohungen und beleidigungen die schwer
zu ertragen sind immer wieder aufrufe
zur
gewalt lässt sie das völlig kalt
das lässt mich nicht kalt aber sie haben
ja gefragt also ob ich wenn ich etwas
schreibe sage oder wenn ich also etwas
sagen aber bewährte ob ich dann darüber
nachdenke werde ich dafür mehr gehasst
oder wie also wird hansi flick reagieren
oder was war sich also was denken die
was denkt die parteiführung
darüber denke ich nicht nach ich
versuche das wirklich nicht also meine
arbeit beeinflussen zu lassen weil also
ich versuche wirklich so glaubwürdig und
also nah an dem was ich als einmal
einschätzen kann zu arbeiten wie geht
wenn ich diesen gedanken hätte also wie
kommt das bei b man dann also dann wäre
es nur noch halb so viel wert ich glaube
dass also daher sage ich auch machen
manchmal etwas was gegen mich verwendet
werden kann ich hatte zum beispiel bei
darauf hingewiesen als wir sagen wir mal
also vieles geschlossen hatten in der
gastronomie und die also sorge war die
dass sich das geschehen das feiern aus
essen und so weiter dass ich das ins
private verlagert da hatte ich mal
gesagt dass wir natürlich nicht zulassen
dürfen dass quasi also im innenraum in
der wohnung alles zugelassen ist das war
dann verletzt worden so nach dem motto
als wenn ich vorgeschlagen hätte die
polizei darf dann in die wohnung ein
kommen wie bei der terrorfahndung
schlägt mit autogramme die wohnungstür
ein und nach dort einer durchsuchung das
war natürlich nicht mein vorschlag
sondern ich hatte also darauf quasi
hingewiesen
ähnlich wie bei einer ruhestörung muss
es auch möglich sein also sagen wir
private feiern zu unterbinden wenn wir
das ganze im öffentlichen raum
unterbinden
aber so etwas ist dann verletzbar wenn
ich aber jetzt bei allem was ich sage
darüber nachdenke also wie kann das
verhetzt werden
wie kann das zum beispiel von vw soll
genutzt werden um eine weitere sein
kampagne gegen mich in der afg zu
starten so dann hätte ich erstens viel
zu tun und zum zweiten käme ich dann
tatsächlich also in einer sprache und
denkt was hinein
die wird also für mich sehr schwer sein
so dass sie so in der öffentlichkeit
stehen und dass sie durch das was sie
sagen so polarisieren das hat ja
auswirkungen bis in den privaten bereich
ihre familie wird plötzlich beachtet in
dem fall zum beispiel ihre ex-frau die
ist epidemiologin wie sie nur das sie in
dieser pandemie den genau
entgegengesetzten standpunkt vertritt
ist das so eine art großen krieg oder
oder wie kannst du so was ich habe mit
ihr ich gesagt seit mehr als 15 jahren
16 jahren kann kontakt von daher weiß
ich ehrlich gesagt nicht was ihre motive
sind wie ich auch nicht nur bei
spekulieren
januar gesehen also dass sie anderer
meinung ist und dabei also belasse ich
es auch sie war sehr renommierte also
krebs epidemiologin und von da ich dass
es einfach mal so stehen aber es für
mich definitiv kein anlass jetzt also
meine meinung zu ändern
reden wir über was erfreulicheres als
als die ex-frau sie haben fünf töchter
die jüngste ist glaube ich 14 45 kinder
jüngste tochter ist 14 wie reagieren
denn ihre kinder darauf dass der vater
plötzlich jeden tag im fernsehen ist und
so populär ist oder berühmt ist aber
eben auch so angefeindet wird
ich möchte ehrlich gesagt auch nicht
über meine kinder sprechen also als ich
also aus dem politischen fernen ich
glaube das also ist auch richtig
okay das respektieren wir dann habe ich
noch eine frage zum abschluss wo ist die
fliege geblieben
die pflege ist quasi im kleiderschrank
und da wird sie auch auf absehbare zeit
bleiben weil sie war irgendwie aus der
zeit gefallen ich hatte mich also schon
länger nicht mehr richtig wohl mit der
fliege gefühlt und jetzt in dieser zeit
das ist keine fall das ist keine zeit
zum feiern
eine fliege sieht ja so ein bisschen
festlich aus also da danach ist mit
derzeit überhaupt nicht und hier muss
man tatsächlich also sagen gab es viel
kritik auch von jüngeren leuten aber
auch viel zustimmung aber irgendwie ich
habe mich damit nicht mehr wohlgefühlt
von daher also liegt sie im garten in
den kleiderschränken
das war phoenix persönlich hatte mit
professor karl
lauterbach herzlichen dank und bleiben
sie gesund
[Musik]